last question today hey David what do
you think about Blaire white leaving
politics yes so Blaire white is a
transgender woman and that's relevant
for this cut this question Blaire white
said that she is sick of these
right-wing media darlings who as she
says it are faking their views in order
to make money and to get attention she
says that she's met some of these
right-wingers who don't believe the
things they say about transgender people
she says that a major news network tried
to get her to follow a script in a
debate with another trans person on a
transgender bill and as a result she's
leaving politics so here's my answer I
sympathize and empathize with her
frustrations and her reasons for saying
I am self-selecting out because this is
so toxic I disagreed that removing
herself is actually going to be good
because in the same way that I decided
to appear on Fox News because even
though it is a setup to make the left
look bad and even though it is damaging
for Fox News to exist versus for it to
not exist my presence was at least an
opportunity to do the right thing and to
do the best I can and to advocate for
the policies that I think are good so if
the question is do I agree with Blaire
white that she shouldn't participate in
stage debates absolutely that's
absolutely ridiculous and I wish I had
more information about exactly where
that happened and maybe we'll hear about
it at some point do I think that
self-selecting out of all political
discourse is a net positive I think the
answer is no regardless of where I agree
in disagree agree with Blaire white I
think she's kind of right-wing I don't
know too much about her but I think
she's kind of right-wing and overall I
think that people who at least defend
the right types of debate they don't
have to have the right position but if
they actually want to have unstaged fair
proper discourse that's respectful I
think those are the types of people that
we need in politics and so I would urge
her not to do this and to out all of the
actors the people who are taking views
they don't even agree with merely for
attention I think we know who some of
them are because their views have
changed drastically over the last few
years and have talked about some of
those people I think that these are the
good people who should stay in politics
because if we all leave it's only gonna
be the bad guys left who participate in
bad faith and that's bad for everybody
that does it for today's program we've
got a great bonus show scheduled for you
get the bonus show by becoming a member
at WWE pakman.com you can also get the
bonus show by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show